one of the most revolutionary products
ever written was the hundred and twenty
one pace culture of Netflix you have to
see the future in ways that other people
can't
Patty who was read at that time here's a
geeky engineer so there's a methodology
I want to teach you that will encompass
when to fire when to fire you hire I
have a hard time with companies that
still do five year planning you know
that you're just making up the other
three years right that's why I know what
we do well let's dance let me let me ask
the question let me ask a question cuz I
wanna go specific do you know the
company are going up against through a
blockbuster and one of the analysts
asked of the CEO of blockbuster what do
you think of Netflix stop asking me
about that stupid little company love
them they are an at they are no one no
one will ever use this stuff what does
he owe me to you you're the breadwinner
of this family you've gotta grow up read
if you want to follow then god damn it
leave Wow
[Music]
when I read her book it's called
powerful antibodies read it in here yet
you've already read it some of you guys
hurt you speaking powerful if you are in
a business with employees recruiting
hiring firing HR you want to find out
how to create a winning culture you have
to read this book all-powerful I'll tell
you right now on believable book when I
read it and I've read 1500 books so I
read this book and I'm going through it
and you see Sheryl Sandberg talk about
the fact that one of the most
revolutionary products ever written
written in Silicon Valley was the
hundred and twenty one page thing that
they came up with the culture of Netflix
her and Reed Hastings together they
created this culture the website with
this presentation of what their culture
has been built does anybody know how
many people clicked on this website to
read their culture anybody knows the
number fifteen million people it got 15
million clicks by the way you know who
clicks on an article like this that has
to do with HR and culture people that
are info there's not 15 million people
that are interested in HR is 15 million
people that are in that world like
yourself and as you go through the
process and unpack the kind of culture
they built it's very controversial very
different she may say it's normal to her
but it's very different than most people
that's why I wanted to bring her down
for us to sit down with her and see how
she went from being at Netflix 14 years
helping the company with the team
members that they had read and everybody
else build the company from zero to
going up against the company at that
time blockbuster that was an eight
billion dollar company and now Netflix
is the powerhouse of our nearly a
hundred and fifty billion dollar company
please help me bring up patty McCord
[Applause]
hi thanks for coming out I mean you have
to make your work
thank you
all right
so Patti what I hear is the fact that
you're at a different event you're
speaking at that event you took a quick
flight to come you got to get back to
the event I did is that really we had a
flat tire planes with flat tires
literally well I'm glad whoever changed
the flat tires is here they probably
called the triple-a I don't know planes
go xxx yes yeah I was really fascinated
by your story and what you build
literally when I started going through
I'm like and maybe part of it was
because I'm going through right now with
hiring an HR person and we're going
through that culture but the timing was
so perfect why I'm like people need to
know about the kind of culture you guys
built so one is before we go through the
story of you know what's happened what's
taking place with the business on how
Netflix became the success story that it
is maybe let's go back at the infancy
stages of the business while you guys
were first going through it you know
beginning stages while you're working
with Reed Hastings you know did you guys
really know what you had was it like yes
we're gonna one day do it was a vision
what was it okay let me tell you the
priests story because it's a good story
Reed and I worked together at another
company which was a software tools
company Reed was an engineer he wrote
the original prod product we grew
through merger and acquisition in the
five years we were together we went
public and acquired four other companies
every company that we acquired was twice
as when we got together we were twice as
big so we were 100 people 200 400 800
1600 and then we got acquired by our
largest competitor and honestly it was
my first big HR job I started out as a
recruiter and and Reed hired me because
it was the only skill he thought was
actually necessary in HR it was like all
that other stuff is but your
recruiter saw I'll hire you so he flat
out said that to you he flat out said
that to me after he hired me probably
wouldn't have taken the job if he hadn't
so we sold the company I read made a
bunch of money and he invested in a
bunch of startups and one of them was
Netflix and for those of you hora in the
US anybody use dvd-by-mail okay so the
first product was so
so he calls me up in the middle and I
and I knew about the idea because he had
told me about it he says are you
sleeping and I said yeah geek I'm normal
it's 2:00 in the morning
and he said I'm gonna go run Netflix and
I said sounds like a great career move
you go for it big guy
and he said well I want you to come too
and I'm like Ian no I need to go back to
sleep because first of all who's gonna
use this product there's only I only
knew for people that had DVD players
they cost $1500 right and so I'm like
what's your since my since 94 is this
ninety six seven I said four you know
I'm consulting my kids know my name I'm
having a pretty good time don't ask me
to do a start-up with you I know what
you're talking about go call a stranger
and say startup would be fun but and
third of all this is the dumbest idea
I've ever heard and he said I'll make it
compelling I'll make it so that you
can't say no and I said there isn't a
possible thing you could say to me and
he said what if we build a company that
was really successful and we loved
working there and we we just built the
kind of company we wanted to work in
okay now I'm awake and I said well how
do you know my question if we did that
how would you know and he said oh I'd
want to walk in the door and solve these
problems with these people every day I'm
like damn that's good
and he said how about you how'd you know
and I said wouldn't it be great if we
were a great place to be from like
having netflix on your resumes meant
something because i was in i didn't I'm
a recruiter right like you were at Apple
Wow
you know so I didn't know at that time
how profound my statement was because
when you build a company that is a great
place to be from and you say that you
want it full of people who when they
leave which most people do that they
walk away saying god that was it I I did
something that was an unbelievable with
people that I really loved working with
I accomplished something that people use
right
and so you know I had two that was
compelling but the beginning was you
know we were blockbuster online we had
due dates and late fees we couldn't get
any content nobody would sell us
anything we bought DVDs at Walmart I
would go to Walmart with my shopping
cart and fill it full of DVDs it really
it was bad yeah let me ask at that time
a patty who was read at that time like
meaning what kind of repetition did he
have with you of working with them well
the we had solved the company that we
were in together for quite a bit of
money and so we made the investors a lot
of money so it was pretty golden in
terms of rainmaking but in terms of the
man I knew you know when I met him he
was I would have to lecture him in the
morning and say look if you're gonna
sleep under your desk please get the
fuzz out of the beard in the morning
because it looks tacky right he was a he
was a geeky engineer and his
transformation to a great leader was
when he realized I caught him one night
this is at the first company I caught
him one night I walked in it's like
seven o'clock at night he's at his
computer you know in the glow of its
computer and I said oh are you working
on the slides for the company meeting
tomorrow he's like yeah that's what I'm
working on I walked behind him and I
said you're bug fixing you found a bug
in the software and you're working eyes
like well somebody's got to do it I'm
like yeah somebody's got like how about
these people that we hired to do it you
have a big speech tomorrow read if you
want to follow then god dammit lead Wow
and I stomped at was this prior this is
not Netflix at that time is he no no no
Martin like does he have a name like he
is read like do they look at him as no
it's just another Silicon Valley I mean
he successfully made a bunch of money
and so that makes you famous right
having a successful IPO is important
he's not famous like he is now and that
so so at Netflix like what was different
was we both made a commitment to each
other that we would try to create some
the best possible place we could and we
didn't mean people were happy right
because I'm not very touchy-feely you
can read it my book
but he's ever called me touchy or feely
but you have people hug you when they
left him people cried when they saw you
a couple years later after work you know
I used to do when I first started
speaking I would do a lot of talking
about how your employees aren't your
family and you shouldn't use the word
family and then when people meet me they
say and they read my book and they meet
me and they say you know I hope you're
not offended but you're pretty nice like
I kind of didn't expect you to be nice
and I didn't expect you to be warm and
you know I'm the queen of the good
goodbye and I think you can say goodbye
to people with affection and grace and
dignity and I'm really really good at it
and so what I now say is my lifelong
friends are from work right I mean I
would trust my children's lives with the
people I've worked with at Netflix but
it wasn't but it's not a family and it
wasn't always fun that's why you know
like I've been crazy when I love Netflix
I was sort of at the beginning of this
whole San Francisco startup scene and I
would go into all every single office
was really cool and every single office
had plants and every single office was
open and every single office had a
bartender right I'm like really you
raised you know you raised this much
money in your second round and you're
spending it by putting a bartender on
payroll and they're like you know we're
worried we might have some issues of
sexual harassment like you'd think you
got a bar at work and I would talk to
people and they would say you know it's
our job in HR to make people happy and I
would give them this assignment I'll
give you this assignment find two three
people in your organization that are
amazing you know who they are right the
people that really accomplish amazing
stuff and ask them to tell you a story
about tell me about the thing that
you're most proud of right something
that you accomplished that you really
thought made a difference and every
single story will be about something
hard right and so my fundamental belief
is what makes us happy at work so
powerful is accomplishing things it's
always when you go man we didn't think
we could do that we sure didn't think we
could do it by that deadline but we did
right and and it would and the stories
are also always about team efforts right
it's always a we right and if the
persons and I person you probably don't
want to hire me anyway because all of
your companies all of the things that
you're doing it's a team effort so
that's what I just fundamentally believe
and so I find him I really believe that
and then it took me until Netflix so
that was a long way in my career I'm an
old lady to realize that you could
actually build a company with adults and
I don't mean old you know because all of
you know really mature twenty year olds
and we all know really immature forty
year olds right and so we started sort
of screening for adult behavior and so
if you hire people who are adults and
they're smart and they care and they can
and you expect a lot from them it goes
pretty right so let's start with that
let's Alyssa because there's a few
things I'd like to accomplish with this
sit down we have together
one is recruiting two is when it's time
to go three years repositioning and
putting people in better places but the
most important one to start off with is
I mean for Sheryl to say what she said
about what you guys came up with
we're got 15 million hits yeah that's
pretty wild right here's the back story
of the Netflix culture Dec tell us
so when Reed and I went to Netflix the
thing that we vowed to each other that
would be different was we would we would
actively control the culture as much as
we could we would be deliberate about it
we wouldn't let it happen and so what we
would do in order to do that as we'd
write it down so at the time read was a
guy who thought in PowerPoint he does
outlines right so PowerPoint is good for
him and so he said let's have an off
site and we're going to talk about
values and I said let's not we've got a
business to figure out and it's usually
just an esoteric waste of time you know
and Ron said integrity and they carved
in marble and they didn't mean it so I
don't want to do that like tell me what
to put on a t-shirt we'll buy some
t-shirts I don't care and I said but you
know what I will do I will write down
behaviors let's write down like if we
say integrity we need to say this is
what it looks like this is
but you act like when you have integrity
and this is what it looks like when you
don't and if you don't you don't work
here anymore it's gonna be that
straightforward so we did that and if
you those of you have ever seen the
Netflix culture deck that's the first
part of it we rewrote that section seven
times because we would what we do is
we'd get back with all the leaders of
our team and we'd say okay let's go
through this name a person that's doing
this name a person that's doing this
name and if we couldn't we would say is
that a value that really matters is that
a behavior that we care is that are we
true - okay that's chapter one okay
in the year 2000 we were gonna go public
we were pitching our IP on Sand Hill
Road we were drinking champagne and
eating caviar and we're gonna have a
hundred dollars stock and private jets
because pets.com did and webbed and did
and so it was our turn I mean after all
and we were gonna be a portal we were
gonna be sell ads and movie stars and
we're gonna be everything entertainment
and the bubble burst and the bankers
pulled the IPO and we didn't make it
is this a town where you lost that dough
to your employees yeah so the but this
is when we laid off 30 percent of the
workforce yeah so it was we ran out of
money and so we had one chance to make
it we really gonna the business was
gonna be a subscription business right
so we had to build a base and every
marketing dollar that we spent acquiring
a new customer was a dollar that was
lost because it didn't come back in the
subscription for many months actually so
I said goodbye to anybody whose job it
was to tell somebody else what to do all
of middle management anybody who wasn't
technically competent to work on
dvd-by-mail only anybody who was a baby
or a whiner because I just couldn't I
couldn't tell the guy who complained
about the color of his t-shirt that we
literally didn't have any money left for
t-shirts so we did that it was a it was
very difficult for us but that Christmas
so now it's 2001
DVD players drop to $99 if you're in the
u.s. you had one under your Christmas
tree and in that DVD player box was a
coupon that said try netflix for free
and our business went how'd you get that
contract you know which I I went into
Best Buy what boxes stuffed in envelopes
because we got a deal with Best Buy that
they would let us do it in certain DVD
player box so you so wait a minute let
me get this straight you guys put that
in there yeah yeah we're scrappy baby
we're scrappy I mean we're all scrappy
stuff you know and we cuz we couldn't we
couldn't put him in in China he can
afford the plane ticket to China it's
great so business takes off and by the
way I'm still thinking about that's
insane
did you guys that's insane that's great
love it yeah okay but yeah we knew when
we were doing well because we didn't
have a bartender it's when I went over
with my shopping cart and got beer that
wasn't in cans to celebrate something
okay so business is going crazy we're
working harder than we've ever worked
Reid and I are driving to work one day
and I'm like I've never worked this hard
in my life he goes me too I'm like I've
never had this much fun in my life and
he goes me too
what is it let's figure it out right and
so we realize everybody is so focused
and everybody and and here's how we
would win right this is the only hope we
had was to make our products so much
better that you'd get addicted to it
that you wouldn't ever want to give it
up right and so the only metric that
mattered was our customer and we knew
that they liked it because they stayed
because it was a subscription service
right
and so we had to constantly constantly
improve improve improve improve and
inside of the company we started
changing the way we communicated with
each other where if anybody would opine
about something or have
yeah or disagree with something it kind
of whatever the sentence was it had to
end with because it affects the customer
right if you're being a jerk and my team
doesn't want to work with you then
that's really problematic because we're
wasting a bunch of time and we got to
get make this feature for our customer
as soon as we can right because this is
a really thing that they'll really want
but so it was like comma for the
customer okay so that's when we wrote
the chapter in the culture deck called
high performance and that's when we
described what we thought were
high-performing people adults smart good
judgment make the right call would be
able to go out and talk to other people
on the team to be able to be good team
players then when I and it probably took
me four years to create the systems to
actually have high performance people
would say that to create systems yeah
really great recruiting team and I had
to have an and I and if I if the
business changed if I hired you to build
something and two years in you had built
it and you were done and now I needed
you to maintain it and you don't want to
maintain it you're a builder I'm not
gonna put you on a performance
improvement plan you're performing right
over time I would realize that I could
just say I think you're done so what do
you want to do here because we only had
one product I couldn't send him
somewhere else in the company right and
so I what are you instead of doing a 90
day performance and performance
improvement plans now this took me years
that's why I'm telling you it took me
years eventually I could say I don't
think this is gonna work out here's
three months pay you want to work on
your next great job right so I'm gonna
segue into a lesson I want to teach you
about this but but so then we wrote high
performance so the Netflix culture deck
took ten years to write because it took
ten years to figure it out so another
day we're driving to read my car pulled
a lot he says I met this woman last
night
created this really cool company they
put PowerPoint decks on the Internet I
said that is such a great idea I wonder
what people are gonna put out there and
he said oh I put the deck up it was an
internal onboarding document we didn't
write that to be a viral treatise on how
to run your company we wrote it so that
when you join Netflix we could say oh by
the way we should tell you how it works
around here and I freaked out okay so
anybody seen the Netflix culture deck
that PowerPoint presentation it's ugly
as sin I said oh god read it so the
graphics
I mean arrows and the yin and yang you
know people kind of loved it because it
was so dorky he said you never told me
it was dorky I'm like yeah I didn't want
to hurt your feelings and and then I
said you're gonna scare all our
candidates because in the culture deck
it says adequate performance gets a
generous severance package and he said
only the ones we don't want but what it
did for us was it made our interviewing
process really rich because we didn't
just talk about were you qualified for
the job we talked about how do you like
to work what kind of team player are you
what's important to you where are you at
in your career right is it is it title
that you're chasing right now because we
don't have any I mean I called seniors
I've called people senior software
engineers they're like you have one
title for software engineers what's the
salary range like oh like 72 seven
hundred thousand how do you know you're
senior I'm like oh you know you know you
know right okay so that's how the
culture deck was written that's how it
was not we didn't release it that's how
it went viral we had no clue that people
would pick it up like they did a crazy
the reason why I wrote my book was that
when I left Netflix every CEO in the
world would throw the culture deck down
say I want to do this and I would say by
the way newsflash it took 10 years to
write and so I wrote my book and my book
is like The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Netflix culture deck so there's a
methodology I want to teach you all of
you that will encompass when to fire
to fire who to hire but that that I
think is really helpful and it's this
imagine your team six months from now
and I think six months is a really good
amount of time because our businesses
move so fast now I have a hard time with
companies that still do five-year
planning I'm like you know that you're
just making up the other three years
right we all know that right
so let's say in six months you have a
team that is amazing not better amazing
like your competitors the other people
around you're like oh my god these
people I can't believe what they're
accomplishing and I want you to write
down what's going to be occurring then
that's not occurring now you can give me
all your numerals if you're a metrics
person is it more customers is it better
retention is it a better quality
software is a better customer experience
whatever that is right and give me all
those numbers but then walk around your
company and make a movie of it I can't
help it I'm from Netflix right and you
make a movie of it like if it was
optimal with there being more meetings
or would there be less meetings would
there be people who stand up and go it
sounds like what they're doing its
marketing is crazy I'm gonna go ask them
why instead of going the people in
marketing you're crazy you know right
what's occurring then that's not
occurring now because I want to give you
I want you to think about those
behaviors and and for smaller companies
very often the problems that you reach
when you actually are going to be
successful are no longer problems of
difficulty they're problems of scale or
complexity right so in six months you
might need somebody who really knows how
to take this rocket ship and really make
it successful and everybody you have on
your team's been there since the
beginning but they don't know anything
about a hundred times okay so we got
that you got that rent out now drop down
a level and go huh what would people
need to know how to do in order to
accomplish that in six months very
important that we put time wrappers on
this because otherwise as leaders of
companies especially small companies we
get caught in the trap
of some day right and we tell people you
know you yeah you could do it you could
be CFO someday rock on you do it you can
do that right you say that but no people
do you told me I could be CFO and I say
yeah but you're an Accounts Payable
Clerk right you know that you can't be
CFO now why not
so Suleiman let me get this straight so
you're saying you guys didn't say
something that's well let's think let me
let me ask the question let me ask the
question cuz I wanna go specific so so I
say I can't be a I asked you a question
hey one day I'd like to be a CFO yep and
I'm Accounts Payable
yep what do you tell me I say have you
thought about a reasonable and rational
timeframe to accomplish that right and
you say well there's a CFO opening here
and I'm I'd like to be qualified for it
and I say you're not because here's what
the qualifications for a CFO would be in
a public company so there's you know you
don't know anything about tax you don't
know anything about audit you don't know
so these are all things that you will
learn in your career let's just be
realistic about the timeframe okay so
back to my methodology
okay now I'm six months out what do you
need to know how to do then you drop
down say what kind of skills and
experience would it take for somebody
know how to do that in order to
accomplish that in six months and then
and only then who's on your team now
right and if you start with who's on
your team now and you extrapolate out
you'll you'll do more you'll get better
but you might not get as good as you
could if you didn't articulate the
endgame so when you have that
articulation this is what it's going to
look like these are the problems now you
can go wow this is a problem that nobody
on the team knows how to solve
that's who you hire right and so now you
haven't written a job description
because job descriptions are dumb I mean
I'm in recruiting I know here's what job
description is it's either a description
of somebody who left that you wish
hadn't a fantasy person that doesn't
exist or whatever it takes to get it
approved none of those are who you hire
you want to hire somebody who can solve
this problem that you have in a fairly
short amount of time
and so now when you're recruiting you're
not only recruiting for somebody who's
qualified but you're recruiting for
somebody who goes oh man
I'd love to do that the other thing is
it leaves you open to a lot of different
ways of solving the problem because
otherwise what people tend to do is say
I want to hire something with these
qualifications and I want them to be
really smart and quick on their feet and
intelligent charismatic like someone
like me
maybe me 10 years ago and that's we hire
and like hires like hires like Cara
slack and then you wonder why you don't
have any diversity and any diversity of
thought and you don't have anybody who
knows how to solve a problem that nobody
in the team already knows hot dog okay
so that's how you figure out who to hire
in the same way sometimes when you do
those problems you realize oh oh the
team I have is not the team to do that
so here's my Netflix story we've grown
30% this is what after where things are
going good right this is probably around
2010 right and at this point you've been
there 13 years yeah I've been there a
long time our team is really tied we're
rocking it man this reads on the cover
of Fortune ii CEO the year stock has
grown you know the business has grown
30% quarter over quarter three quarters
in the row
I mean it's we're awesome right so we do
it a session in our executive staff and
I and I said what if this kept up like
because the Britos wants to do disaster
playing I'm like why don't just for once
like what if what if it kept up so CFO
goes the whiteboard and he does top-line
revenue 30% core and so he starts doing
that happy dance let's see if I mean you
can you imagine for those of you who are
the finance people you'd be like so Ted
or a head of content we at the time we
would say to ourselves someday we'll be
as big as HBO someday
and Ted looks at the number and he goes
it's next year right and we just look at
each other like stun and Neil who is our
head of product said I think that's a
third of the US Internet bandwidth I
think we could be streaming a third of
the US Internet bandwidth and we all
just kinda liked each other like so he
and I get together I'm like do we have
anybody that knows how to do that
because know like can we do that in our
data center
oh no no no must be in the cloud so we
sit down with our IT team and these guys
are amazing they're amazing and we lay
out the problem and they're like no
worries you go exec something and we'll
build a cloud and I said you know what
if there's any people in the room
anybody on earth that could do that it's
probably you guys not 9 months we could
stand up the servers right we couldn't
leased the physical space and buy the
equipment and do it and so one of the
people in the room said I've been here
for seven years we wouldn't be here if
it wasn't for me are you telling me I
might not be on this team and I said
yeah I think that's what I'm telling you
and but we got nine months to figure it
out and you know even though people
didn't like that answer it was true and
I've worked with engineers forever and
engineers have the engineers think the
world is good or bad right or wrong
black or white zero one right so it was
like I'm not sure I like that answer but
I can't deny the truth of it and so what
the AHA of that lesson is it's your job
if you're running an organization to
field the team that can win and you
never want to let the talent or lack of
talent in your organization come between
you and what success looks like that's
pretty wild what you just said can you
say that one more time if you're in
charge of running an organization it's
your job to feel the team here's your
dog to create amazing tea
that do incredible work on time with
quality that served the customer period
and the finish it's never to allow the
talent to come in between you and what
your opportunity that's unbelievable
right there so it has your personality
always been like this yeah you're in let
me know if it's this read is read like
you as well yeah here's known that I'm
at the geek part here's what I'm talking
about because the part says you know
when I start speaking HR speak when I
first met him about six months he's like
did you just say anything but that noise
that you made did that like can you tell
me how'd you guys meet in the first
place how'd you go where'd you guys meet
oh this funny story so I was working at
a company called Borland it was a
suffered company and I was working with
one of the company was kind of falling
apart because Microsoft was killing it
and what a view piece that I worked with
his deciding he was a Harvard MBA
whether to go back to Harvard and teach
or go to a startup and so I helped
career counsel and then he went to this
started and I called him up about some
stock or something one time I'm like hey
how'd your new HR guy work out and he
said oh man he was an idiot we fired him
it's just been bad he tells me the story
I'm like oh great well you can hire me
and he said you told me if if I hired
anybody from Borland you'd break both my
legs I said yeah I didn't mean me so he
said I can't do it I told the CEO I
wouldn't recruit anybody out there the
CEOs name is Reed Hastings good luck
so those of you who were old enough back
in the day you could dial star-69 and it
would call back and read sister answered
the phone and I said hi I'm Patti McCord
I'm friends with Rob dickerson can I
speak please speak with Reed Hastings
and she that's literally out and what
did the conversation sound like oh we
got this huge argument because now
remember back in those days I could
still speak it has a difficult site your
personality like there's a consensus
there's a part of you that's difficult
oh yeah okay so he asked me in the
interview tell me about your HR
philosophy Reid I believe in empowering
employees to reach their
so that they can align themselves with
the organizational structure and their
own desires and careers to accomplish
well you know I go into full on HR speak
right burning platforms and he looks me
because people like why do I have to
have somebody like you and my business
you don't speak English honestly that's
how I felt I'm trying to see how you
don't know me yeah I guess well how am I
supposed to know you when you're so I'm
like oh yeah well I know how to do some
things that are pretty darn important
around here right he's like oh yeah like
what I'm like well I'm a hell of a
recruiter and I'm really good with
engineers he's like oh yeah well that
might matter so I go home I go home my
now ex-husband says how'd it go with CEO
and he's like you're the breadwinner of
this family you've got to grow up and
act like a real HR person you're never
gonna get another job
that's how you got started the
relationship so what what what makes an
ideal relationship with the CEO on the
HR so what what makes it effective like
what is the is it very open is it
constant daily communication even if you
hire a traditional HR person you've got
to get them to unlearn that crazy
language that they talk because it's
really stupid and I'm doing a lot for
you in that vein I talked to a lot of HR
people and sometimes I don't want to but
you know I say the doors close it's just
us I'm one of you you got to stop using
a language that nobody knows where that
but us the language you must speak is
the language of the business so don't
put anybody in the role who it doesn't
deeply understand your business they
should be able to read a P&L and they
should be able to derive from that
business plan exactly what the team
structure should look like that's their
added value HR people HR has three
components as far as I'm concerned one
of them is staffing staffing is really
really critical and staffing is your job
it's not HR job if you have a great
partnership with your recruiting or your
staffing team then you'll find the right
talent but finding the right talent for
your team is a job that you do all the
time did I say all the time all the time
your job meaning CEO your job absolutely
okay it is your job it's your job to be
scouting for talent constantly and it's
your job to do that because you set the
example for everybody else in your
organization that it's their job to
build great teams and they can't build
great teams if they rely on a bunch of
people in HR that they think are stupid
okay question for you give me some
examples on how you saw read constantly
looking for talent seventy one time and
I said I know her he goes yeah she's a
head of HR Yahoo Yahoo I'm here he's
like you can get hit by a bus look
that's a good point and he's like I just
you know wanted to see what other people
are doing see if there's anything we
should try what year of your career was
this Oh at this point I was pretty
confident you know because read it asked
me to come to Netflix oh no no meaning
this one when this was different way
20-something problem no no no not in
your what year of Netflix was it was it
was it like 50 or 40 okay so the only
person donors I'm asking this question
you said your job CEO you said Scout and
you're always scouting what were some
ways that Reid was scouting for talent
just wherever in a meeting like this to
meet you you know it's and very often my
experience is a recruiter in all these
years when I coach people about looking
for work I say it's not what you know or
who you know it's who knows what you
know so every person that you meet is a
conduit to somebody else so for example
in my team I'm like we give good
interview I'm telling you we want every
single person that walks in here to walk
on go god I hope they hire me even if we
hate them because we want them to do you
know to be at their kids soccer match
and say to the dad next to them what do
you do oh you know why it's just
interviewing at Netflix and I wasn't the
right person but you sounds like you
might be
should I tell them about you right so
that's mine recruiting my earlier I'm a
very good technical recruiter so in
Silicon Valley this probably happens
wherever you are the engineers had this
habit of like there is the ethnic
restaurant dejour we're all eating Thai
food or you know it's all about Korean
barbeque and they're always these little
hole-in-the-wall restaurants in a next
to a nail salon and a strip mall and I
find out where those restaurants were
and so in those restaurants they have a
like fishbowl you put your business card
in you get a free lunch so I'd walk in
and take the fishbowl whose before
cellphones right in the internet they go
to a table in the back corner I'd dump
oh man I just start writing gun names go
back and call now so so so God gave you
LinkedIn yeah so right God gave you
social networking okay so that's
staffing the next component of HR is the
administrative and compliance component
that's payroll and benefits and all the
legal labor law stuff that stuff is
really really important you want people
in those roles who really really love
accuracy you want them to wake up in the
middle of an I can go I spelled your
name wrong you want them to know all the
rules you don't want them to make any
their answer to can we as always know
right so but that's okay you need
somebody to know what those things are
so I put that in Netflix eventually in
finance or in legal the dilemma of
putting that's because those guys
sometimes don't have the best customer
service so it's an internal thing then
the third component is the component
about organizational structure and
design leadership coaching the being
honest with being I call it being a
mirror to your organization so you have
to know the business and you have to
know what your values are and you have
to be able to say truthfully to anybody
in the organization I think we could do
better right and you have to be able to
honestly for me I mean I'm I practice a
lot so I could say to somebody bring
them in the room and close the door and
go you know you're kind of an
and I'm not gonna tolerate I know reeds
in love with you and I know you're
brilliant and I know you also want to be
a VP when you grow up so here's the deal
VP's run teams VP's who run the
effective teams are ineffective teams
because people want to work for them and
do great work and nobody wants to work
with you they don't like you they don't
like to be a meetings with you they'd
get bummed when they're put on your team
you got to change that dude because
that's what's gonna make success for you
I'll help you because I'd really like
you to not be an it'd be a
brilliant guy that can contribute to our
company he's still very sick what's next
I'll help you what does that mean what's
next for me no you said I'll help you if
you want to be a VP one day but you
can't be one being an
yeah so when you say I'll help you what
is that help I need that help for two
this course was for me to see him see
his team in a meeting walk in the room
and sit down
he's like Patti what are you doing here
my in the neighborhood just thought and
then I would I would say Todd excuse me
but you're doing it right now
cuz he didn't know he's like yeah I've
gotten that feedback before I'm like but
you didn't do anything about it so most
people who have did really got as well
or now but was that your role no no
meaning yes that assigned to you or he
did it as well I work together for 25
years so you know this is a long long
time we could but but we worked really
hard on he and I modeling the kind of
relationship we wanted other people to
have so we would so we used to go in the
early days we took the company to the
Sundance Film Festival that was our
annual event and every year Reid and I
would have a bottle of wine together got
progressively better by the way that
bottle of wine and the bottle went
together that we would have would be the
discussion which would say Nick what's
on what's on our plates for next year
and am I still the right person what's
on our plate mix here and are you still
the right person or if he's still the
right person like what do you think our
strengths and weaknesses are going to be
next year so for example when
have a dvd-by-mail business I said you
know read I think we're gonna have we
could have like 5,000 employees and I
think 4,000 of them are gonna work in
warehouses and drive cars you know drive
trucks and put DVDs into envelopes I
think we're gonna have a lot of
blue-collar direct labor at work for us
and he's like yeah I could see that I'm
like I don't know what minimum wage is
hmm I mean I've so far away from this
kind of workforce
I had just I'm not your gal to do this
like I don't do we have to do they have
to be bonded I mean what are the rules
around this kind of worker and he goes
yeah you'd probably suck at that and I
said yeah I probably wouldn't he was but
then if we got somebody who for whom
there was that was their expertise they
probably would suck at relating to
engineers and that's really critical to
our business at the time like yeah it's
true he goes well let's do a six-month
plan you go see if you can find somebody
to do that to work for you who can teach
us both about how we manage that kind of
work for something okay deal right and
then I would say to him by the way you
know you keep you sort of by default
keep flowing into this role where we
can't keep an executive and honestly we
need to find somebody who really owns
this and not you anymore all right cuz
that's gonna hurt us right so tell me
what you mean by you can't keep
executives it was a stitch I forget what
the role was but it was like if there
wasn't anybody in marketing then he'd
run it or data science right the data
science guy wasn't there so they would
report to him I'm like you know really
not helpful for you to run a function
because we kind of would like you to go
CEO something
what does CEO mean to you so what is the
CEO job a good seal what is it what is
she you know has a couple of great
characteristics one of them is you you
have a you're very smart
good CEOs have good rapid-fire ability
to process information I used to call it
that's old-school now I used to say you
know you want a really big hard drive
you want to be able to have a lot of
recall a lot of information and keep it
there the second thing is you have to be
able to see the future in ways that
other people can't
and the third thing is you have to be
brave you have to be the first one off
the cliff right nobody's going to jump
unless you do and and you can't spin it
you got to believe it you know here's
here's a read example we have reached a
million customers I mean what a
milestone he's up the company meeting
he's showing the bar graph of a million
customers and afterwards he's like yeah
I want to make a rug of it and just lay
on it like and he goes he goes yes
five million like wait a minute
five minute we just reached a million
we've been working on that goal for four
years and he's like yeah that's that's
so yesterday five that's good number
like instantly I'm like can we have a
party goes I guess if you want but I
mean you know one is was easy now it's
five oh one more startup story engineer
call the engineer says to me penny you
don't understant management doesn't
understand it's not like it used to be
we used to all know each other and we
knew what everybody was doing and we
were all really good friends it's not
like that anymore there's too many
people when we don't get it you know a
management doesn't understand I'm like
Rob I'm a VP I report to the CEO I'm
gonna call me management and we've had
this conversation seven times so part a
of the sentence is untrue management
knows I've talked to read about it okay
second part do you know what we want to
be when we grow up no like we want to be
a global corporation and he just kind of
melts oh that's okay you don't have to
be here you're a 50-person startup guy
now by the way 50 person startups
there's three endings who are startups
bigger smaller eaten smaller is death so
I call that the smoke of nostalgia
beware in your company if you smell the
smoke of nostalgia because you don't get
to go backwards you don't get to keep it
the way it is it's an ever-evolving
thing your business if it's
successful will change so what you want
is a team of people who when things
change don't fret but go yes two
questions for you yeah one in the book
you talked about one year employees came
up to say it
I need fifty employees at fifty thousand
dollars were growing so fast I need you
to help me get this and then you said
why fifty eight fifty why not
twenty-five at 75 25 at 100 why do we
need 50 at 50 so at what point do you
know if we need 50 at 50 or 25 out of
hundred how do you process that you go
through my methodology and you decide
what the problem is you're trying to
solve and so let's say you're trying to
solve a problem of scale and you need
somebody who has a lot of experience
doing it the I think that a story I
found later I don't know if it's in the
book was when I went to a CEO who had
just gotten another round of funding and
he said yeah I really want to talk to
you cuz we're gonna scale from 150 to
300 people I said magic of 300 is that
you think if you hired twice as many
people you'll get twice as much work
done he's like yeah like yeah that's not
gonna happen
you know this is completely chaotic and
so I said are those guys in the corner
taping up boxes to ship your product he
goes yeah I'm like it's San Francisco
your pace and Francisco rents for people
to tape box what are you paying them
well we don't pay them that much I'm
like boy you don't pay them enough to
live here that's for sure
and guess what figuring out how to
efficiently tape boxes that problems
been solved so you don't need another
ten guys in the corner with tape guns
you need nobody with a cardboard box
here in San Fran in San Francisco right
so so that you could outsource right so
that is something absolutely you could
answer
are you still literally building the
product here are those guys I'm
soldering irons I'm like okay and then
how many people do you have in customer
service well yeah we're gonna need lots
more customer service people I'm like
because it doesn't work that well right
he goes yeah I'm like or a couple of
really expensive really great engineers
to help you solve the problem before
it's to the customer right and so what
we did was we walked through
first of all walked through what are the
priorities of business
what was the timeframes of those
priorities and then that same kind of
thing which is in which areas with the
highest priority do we have the weakest
teams and that's where you spend your
money right then you get the absolutely
best people conversely I worked with
another startup that had hired an HR
person they were doing compensation
she's going over her compensation plan
with me and she said yes we've decided
to pay in the 65th percentile and I said
huh why she was well that that seems
like the right thing to do and I said
okay but that's fine that fits in the
budget and all that kind of stuff in
that map matches your headcount I said
but you can't no longer say we only hire
a players okay you can't say that
anymore cuz eight players don't work for
65th percentile and I said if can I be
an employee
what is 65th percentile mean and where's
the other who gets the other 35% she was
well that's not what it means oh I know
it's not it means and you know it's when
nobody else in the world knows what it
means and did you use survey data to
come up with this yes I did I said how
hard was it to match people who ship
razor blades online like if you're gonna
if you're gonna have a compensation
system that makes sense to you a it
should make sense to you and B you
should be really transparent about it
here's how we figure out your pay and my
experience is there are often times so
the story I told you earlier about cloud
computing we extracted a really talented
team out of Yahoo in between CEOs to do
our cloud in between you guys did you
guys exploit that opportunity absolutely
so we okay so let me ask you to the part
about pure competition
what was the idea like we got a you know
extract best talent from this company
put these guys out of business was it a
sure what you said absolutely sounded
very competitive
feel that all is fair in love and war in
recruiting that's the point that's the
and I mean it both ways if you tell me
you want to be a CFO and you're actually
pretty close and I might need a CFO in a
couple of years and I'm busy working
with you on it and you're a talented guy
and I like you and I don't want you to
leave sure but somebody reaches out to
you and says I gotta see I see
CFO position in my company right now I
think you'd be amazing that well I want
you to take it right I can't I can't
have you had that conversation balute
Lee absolutely I've had more it's like
hey you were talking to so and so what
were you talking to him about I'm like
that it's time for him to go he's like
you were telling our employees to leave
happy and not into the work anymore and
he's got all these other opportunities
and every day he walks in feeling like
he passed another one by here's here's
the Google story that's in my book we
had this guy that he was a university
hire at Cisco he'd been at Cisco for
like a year and then we brought him over
to work with our most talented most
senior engineer working on the
personalization algorithms the AI and
our business and so he was sort of his
protege for about five years and the
personalization algorithms at netflix
are deep deep core software deep core
talent in part of our business right so
he's been there about five years and his
boss calls me up and says John got an
offer from Google at twice the salary
I'm like well tell him like not
let the door hit him in the butt on the
way he's not worth twice is he hit
Google can't pay anybody Google's got
more money good doesn't really you're
saying I'm saying that my reptilian HR
brain kicks in and I'm like no no he
doesn't look just tell him to go to
Google and they're like he can't go to
Google he's critical to us see that's
what happens when we make one person the
center of our product and it shouldn't
be like that we should be more - sir
nope so then the VP gets in then Reid
gets in we're emailing back and forth
all weekend Sunday more
I wake up and I'm like oh my god of
course they want him who else knows what
he knows I mean I'm thinking we can't
hire anybody because there's nobody that
so I sent an email at I say I was wrong
I I just looked at the salaries of
everybody on that team we can double it
and it's nothing to the PNL I can go
I'll do as soon as I get into work
they're buddies like you're supposed to
say no and who's everybody with twice so
so but what we did was we started to
have the real conversation we needed to
have which was oh my god my dream came
true
now having worked here makes you more
valuable and I started thinking about so
this is where my I'm hanging around with
inventors all the time right
so now I'm thinking wait a minute oh my
god all these companies that worry about
retention when their compensation system
is so restrictive that it makes people
and John came in he goes I heard you've
been talking about my offer at Google
I'm like yeah he says I can't say no I
got a family I mean it's not nobody it's
Google me that's pretty cool opportunity
so you know I want to stay but it's
twice my salary and you know he's like I
might be worth it and he was so he told
you I might be worth it yeah over time
what I realized was for the four people
that you want to stay that are really
critical to the business you can't keep
them that's you can't change their dose
you don't retain people it doesn't work
but you can take money off the table as
a issue right and I and I used to tell
people this also got me in trouble
with all my fellow HR people who are
they do this I said to everybody look I
know you're being recruited all the time
I know the headhunters call you I know
that we're very popular right now but
I'm trying to figure out what real
market data is for
guys and it's hard because it's shifting
so when the headhunter calls please
before you say no thanks
be sure you say how much and come tell
me so I would know what other people
were offering them and then I just went
through the company quarterly and looked
at particularly teams that we'd done a
lot of hiring on and said well so
everybody we hired makes more money than
the people we have is it there we just
hired a bunch of better people which can
be right you hired more senior people
and you pay them more or is it that the
people that you want to stay on the team
should could leave and get jobs at a
better salary right so that's just ice
you know when you start to think about
it
everything so my bigger message to you
is the way you think about your product
the way you think about your customer
the way you think about innovation you
can apply all of that to managing people
last question for we wish you the best
how did it feel when you were going
through the process of maybe you're
competing maybe you're now but you know
the company are going up against at
beginning stages of a blockbuster and
then they went out of business what was
that like for you when that took place
like what conversation that you and Reid
have about a pretty one we we used to
listen to the blockbuster earnings call
everybody in the company would go into a
conference room enlist said to the
blockbuster earnings call on the Polycom
you remember those that set in the
middle of year and we'd all sit around
the table at like listen and one of the
analysts asked John AG Tioga the CEO of
blockbuster what do you think of Netflix
and he said the stop asking me about
that stupid little company love that
they are a gnat they are no one no one
will ever use this stuff it's too hard
as he did not play that right people
loved the video stores were the largest
video retail renter in the globe Wow and
I'm looking at my CMO who's sitting
across from me and behind her on the
whiteboard is our customer growth right
and I like I told you it's like we went
oh my god he he doesn't know
right Reid had tried really gone to sell
us the year before hey you want to buy
her service he's like no I know I don't
forget whatever it was you know forty
million dollars so so then we get to the
company meeting and people are like do
it and we're like yeah so here's our
strategy like lay low
give it up Patti McCord I got a gift for
you
I gotta get free amazing I gotta get
free go let me get to give alright come
on
so I figured it just made sense to get
your old blockbuster bag and I got you
some special limited edition DVD one
week rental one week rental for okay and
then I also know you love sailing
appreciate not gonna take this with you
well you know we had to call a few
people but we got it for you so you can
go frame it and do whatever you want to
do with it make noise so Patti report
[Applause]
thank you so much